and now it's time for our seen and
unseen segment we exposed the big
cultural stories of the day tonight a
holiday you've probably met have heard
of a Grammy surprise and more joining us
now with all the details Raymond Arroyo
Fox News contributor New York Times
bestselling author of the book wheel
wilder and the amulet of power that the
Ingram children are reading because I'm
ready to them available at bookstores
starting on Tuesday all right Raymond
tomorrow is Valentine's Valentine's Day
but today I guess I missed my
opportunity not yet
what is it it's apparently gallant on
Valentine's Day now Laura this so-called
holiday entered the cultural
consciousness in 2010 with an episode of
Parks and Rec now it's become a
phenomenon here's the episode in
question and then I'll tell you what's
happening what's galentine's day oh it's
only the best day of the year every
february 13th my lady friends and I
leave her husband's and her boyfriends
at home and we just come and kick it
breakfast style ladies celebrating
ladies Laura now bands of women are
filling restaurants to celebrate each
other Hallmark even has 16 gala lines
and other cards feature greetings like
you are a goddess glorious female
warrior or uterus 'as before du Teresa's
uteri I don't know you know what's
driving this there was a survey by the
National Retail Federation my name only
51 percent of Americans are celebrating
Valentine's Day down from 63 percent in
2007 it's all about the green and you
say st. Valentine you will remember was
beheaded for erroneously marrying
couples the emperor claudius wanted them
outlawed he went forward with marriage
people are losing their heads over the
silly galentine's day thing I don't like
galentine's there's an anti male bias in
galentine's that I don't like it does
seem a bit defensive it's a defensive
holiday it is and you know I've never
been one to sit around with a bunch of
women at this at the table I've always
been more for guys oh well I don't know
why the rocker the restaurants want this
because they want to throw a table full
of ladies and the flower women love
buying flowers and candies and good
candles for each other men oh yeah not a
big thing now we have a Valentine to
share with each other which is family
is yours first I guess but can you put
the doors first you're the right angle
for me I'm Rebecca I love that color
love that is in general yeah there's
another one now okay this would be for
Raymond Arroyo wants to be your boy oh
okay that's definitely you're fired
okay go ahead one person who really
loves himself Laura verge this week
Michelle Obama made a surprise and very
very glamorous appearance at the Grammys
on Sunday now a new techsmith's Erie's
of text messages between her mother and
her have been released and it is a bit
curious
oh then Robyn sent us she's cold we'll
put it up on the screen uh you see the
mother Robinson writes I guess you were
a hit at the Grammys
Michelle writes I'm sitting here with
Valerie Jarrett I guess yeah and this in
this test this text is so typically you
did you watch it and she says I saw it
because Gracie called me did you meet
any of the real stars or did you just
run right after you were done I told you
I was gonna be on it oh you did not I
would have remembered that even though I
don't remember much emoji emoji emoji
laughing I thought I told you and I'm a
real star by the way I am I am a real
star by the way yeah okay she's the only
one that could put Michelle in her place
and she did I love okay Laurie an update
to our Lutz story last week you'll
remember Dave assman of Saskatchewan he
was forbidden by the government from
putting his name on a personalized
license plate well this week he found
some self-love he got a decal of his
name ass man on the rear end of his
pickup tearing all the world to see ass
means it's pronounced time Iseman oh it
isn't Osmond is the original
pronunciation I heard him repeatedly in
interviews he said ass man Dave's my
task man he's proud to be an ass man let
him be proud it's it's his day it's
Valentine's Day he's finding the love
we're not playing the Seinfeld again no
we're not doing that again we're not
doing we did that last week by the way
mother Robinson remember she's to call
into my radio show she did she at least
as someone who said she was okay boy she
said Mr M oh oh you'd never know it was
always a little Fisher I have what is
that gold packet Random House sent me
this I'm opening it on the show oh this
is like talking about like the Grammy
this is the winner is is like the
Grammys and the winner is I can't open
them
you always props pre-done 30 seconds
seconds can I get it open like oh they
sent scissors or cuz they're sent back
they sent it will while they're he's so
excited
I'll share this with you coming out
that's coming up Monday Tuesday Tuesday
bookstores everywhere an adventure for
the family the whole family can take
part on adventure started reading and
Nico's eyes got really big because there
are demons crawling no scary and demons
are crawling on the ceiling that's all
and it's in the Louvre in Paris during
World War two good wins in the end